by now we're used to seeing functions
defined like h of y is equal to y
squared or f of x
is equal to the square root of x what
we're now going to explore is functions
that are defined piece by piece over
different intervals and functions like
this are you'll sometimes
view them as a piecewise or these types
of function definitions they might be
called a piecewise function definition
and so let's take a look at this graph
right over here this graph you can see
that the function is constant over this
interval for x and then it jumps up to
in this interval for x and then it jumps
back down for this interval over x so
let's think about how we would write
this using our function notation so if
we say that this right over here is the
x axis and if this is the y is equal to
f of x axis then let's see our function
f of x
is going to be equal to let's see
there's three different intervals
so let me give myself some space for the
three different intervals now this first
interval is
from
not including negative nine i have this
open circle here not a closed in circle
so not including negative nine but x
being greater than negative 9 and all
the way up to and including negative 5.
so i could write that as negative 9
is less than x
less than or equal to negative 5. that's
this interval and what is the value of
the function over this interval well we
see the value of the function is
negative 9. it's a constant negative 9
over that interval it's a little
confusing because the value of the
function is actually the the also the
value of the the lower bound on this
interval right over here and it's very
important to look at this says negative
9 is less than x not less than or equal
if it was less than or equal then the
function would have been defined at x
equals negative 9 but it's not we have
an open circle right over there
but now let's look at the next interval
the next interval is from x is greater
or negative 5 is less than x
which is less than or equal to
negative 1.
and
over that interval the function is equal
to the function is a constant 6. it
jumps up here sometimes people call this
a step function it steps up it looks
like stairs to some degree now it's very
important here that at x equals negative
5 for it to be defined only one place
here it's defined by this part it's only
defined over here and so that's why it's
important that this isn't a negative 5
is less than or equal to because then if
you put negative 5 into the function
this thing would be filled in and then
the function would be defined to both
places and that's not cool for a
function it wouldn't be a function
anymore so it's very important that this
that it that when you input negative
five in here you know which of these
which of these intervals you are in you
can't be in two of these in two of these
intervals if you are in two of these
intervals the interval should give you
the same value so that the function maps
from one input to the same output
now let's keep going we have this last
interval where we're going from negative
one
we're going from negative one to nine
from negative 1 to positive 9
and x it starts off with negative 1 less
than x because you have an open circle
right over here and that's good because
x equals negative 1 is defined up here
all the way to x is less than or equal
to
nine and over that interval what is the
value of our function well you see the
value of our function is a constant
negative seven
a constant negative seven and we're done
we have just constructed
a piece by piece definition of this
function and actually when you see this
type of function notation
it becomes a lot clearer why function
notation is is useful even and hopefully
well anyway hopefully you you enjoyed
that i always find these piecewise
functions a lot of fun